symbole de l'extrême violence des
affrontements d'hier ces véhicules de
gendarmerie calcinées sur le site de
sainte-solide la mobilisation se voulait
historique ces images le sont déjà aux
abords de la bassine de sainte Soline
très vite la tension est montée d'un
cran transformant les champs de culture
en champ de bataille j'ai de pierre de
cocktail Molotov explosion un champ de
bataille Emmanuel Macron et beaucoup de
Français se sont forgés cette conviction
est devenu l'homme du désordre et
l'homme du chaos mais sa date avant lui
en tout cas aussi du premier quinquennat
voyons on a les mêmes échanges là
pour une raison très simple c'est
l'impunité on peut même pas les
identifier politiquement bien sûr que
ils sont de l'ultra gauche si l'on veut
mais ce sont des groupes qui sont là
pour détruire qui sont là pour non pas
pour obtenir le retrait de quoi que ce
soit ou pour empêcher qu'il y ait des
bacides ils sont là pour créer le chaos
ces gens là sont vraiment des nervis
antidémocratiques j'ai moi-même pas
faire à eux j'étais encore hier à
Villeurbanne ou
ces gens voulaient m'empêcher de signer
mon livre et j'ai affaire à eux de
partout où je vais les deux camps
s'affrontent aujourd'hui sur les
chiffres des blessés et se rejettent la
responsabilité le ministère de
l'Intérieur déclare avoir utilisé 4000
grenades lacrymogène ou de
désencerclement je soutiens totalement
les policiers les gendarmes qui depuis
plusieurs jours subissent de la part de
l'extrême gauche des attaques et ont été
plus de 440 sans compter le bilan
aujourd'hui plus de 440 gendarmes et
policiers blessés et effectivement là il
y a un pourrissement par la violence et
qu'il pourra ainsi selon une technique
bien connue apparaître comme l'homme de
l'homme donc c'est de façon délibérée
deux ans de plus sur toute la France les
opposants à la régime des retraites
pourront aller pour aller se faire
[__] à Lille et à Metz
ils pourront aller se faire cuire le cul
sur un feu de poubelle à Rennes et à
Bordeaux l'oura le bol de ceux qui l'ont
finissent pas de subir les désagréments
de la grève des éboueurs après deux
semaines à Paris la situation semblait
doucement s'améliorer mais de nouveau
préavis sont déposés dans 5
arrondissements à partir de ce soir et
allez bien [__] leur génitrice sur
tout pourtour méditerranéen
[Rires]
il est toujours là Olivier
le soleil moi je pense qu'il faut que
nous nous interrogions tous
collectivement syndicats citoyens
politiques qu'ils soient parlementaires
ou gouvernement sur notre incapacité à
réussir à trouver des points d'accord
sur ce type de sujet nous en trouvons
sur beaucoup de sujets mais là nous
voyons que nous avons échoué
sera peut-être non pas de donner le
sentiment d'enlever un droit
mais la possibilité de donner une
liberté nouvelle la cinquième erreur
c'est une erreur de communication on
attendait le président de la République
mardi pour qu'il puisse apaiser et il a
exacerbé en ayant en plus des mots qui
étaient
désagréables pour les leaders de la
série est-ce que vous répondez à
François Hollande
c'est toujours facile de trouver et de
désigner un coupable et moi je crois et
je prends ma part de responsabilité en
tant que président de l'Assemblée
nationale que c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est un échec
collectif les deux motions de censure on
l'a vu on échoué toute façon l'émotion
de censure c'est un petit peu comme les
trajets en bagnole avec Pierre Palmade
ça va jamais vous ça va jamais au bout
c'est trop tard c'est fait elle est
balancée voilà un paysage aplati rasé
sur tout le trajet de la tornade
aucune maison n'a résisté sur son
passage la visite en France Leroy
Charles III et qui était prévue à partir
de demain et reporté à cause des
tensions dans le pays 600 ans après la
Pucelle d'Orléans Philippe Martinez à
lui aussi réussi à bouter les Anglais en
France
mon Filou mon Filou c'est la nouvelle
Jeanne d'Arc